Ni växte även under corona och gick plus under corona.
Vad är det ni gör bra?
Eeeh, oj.
Och inte såhär att vi tar hand om kunderna.
Alla säger det.
Men jag tror faktiskt att mycket handlar om det.
Att det är ändå såhär, folk är ju gymmet som sitt andra hem.
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt.
Det kör vi på.
Det får det bli.
Då går vi vidare.
Då tar vi denna veckan och välkomnar entreprenören Anna Stålnacket i podden.
Ja, hej!
Du är ju en drömgäst faktiskt.
Du är en önskad gäst här i...
Jag tror att det som folk framförallt tycker är fascinerande är att ni faktiskt har byggt upp inte bara ett gym som funkar bra utan ett flertal gym som funkar bra.
Så jag tänkte att vi ska fokusera lite grann på det idag.
Det är ju, som alla vet, det är ju fruktansvärt krångligt bara att driva en anläggning men att få flera stycken att funka och på olika orter och att göra det i samband med allt annat.
Du nickar men det kräver lite energi.
Det kan man ju säga.
Ja, jag tänker att vi ska komma in på det.
Men vi kan väl börja bara lite kort.
Om man nu inte vet vem Anna Stolnack är så kan man ju antingen googla dig eller så kan man bara få en minut kort intro här.
Vem skulle du säga att du är?
En träningsgalen tjej som egentligen älskar allt med träning men har verkligen fastnat i gymmet och kan ju säga då att jag har gymmet både som hobby och som arbete och förutom det är två barns mamma som spenderar mycket tid med mina barn när jag inte jobbar och inte trädar.
Vi kan ju säga att vi fick ställa in första poddinspelningen här som skulle varit för några veckor sedan för då hade ett av dina barn feber och jag har ju två barn och min äldsta hade öroninflammation så att det är det som det är.
På livet med små barn.
Ja, men du driver gymmet men du har lite andra sidogrejer också.
Du står på Instagram.
Ja, man kan väl säga att jag jobbar ju inte alls på Instagram så som man kan tänka att många med mycket följare gör.
Jag gör ju liksom inte samarbeten på Instagram när det inte handlar om mina egna varumärken.
Så jag har väl Instagram mest för att dela med mig av det jag gör på dagarna i mitt liv och det jag jobbar med.
Så jag lyfter ju mycket av de produkterna som jag själv jobbar med.
Och det är ju gymmet då, det är tio anläggningar idag och sen har jag ju en tränningsapp som heter Livity som jag jobbar mycket med och tränningskläder som heter Xshapes.
Hur stor är, inte hur mycket tid du lägger på varumärken, men hur stor är respektive omsättning i de tre olika områdena så att säga?
Alltså man kan väl säga att Livity och gymmen är ju det absolut största av omsättningen.
Livity omsätter snäppet mer än vad ett gymm gör, kan man väl säga.
Och Xshapes tränningskläder, det är klart att de gör en bra omsättning, men inte om man jämför med Livity och gymmen.
Men, ja, de tuffar på oss.
Hur mycket tid ligger du uppdelat på de olika?
Lägger du 95% på gymmen och 5% på övrigt eller är det mer?
Jag skulle nog säga att det kanske är 40% gymmen, 40% Livity och restriktionerande Xshapes.
Är tur att ni äger detta själva, det är ju du och din pojkvän eller man, som äger detta själva.
Annars hade kanske den ägaren sagt att du inte får fokusera så mycket på appen.
Nej men så kan det absolut vara, men nu är vi ju ett och samma bolag och jag tror att mycket går hand i hand.
Det som är positivt för gymmen blir också positivt för Livity och tvärtom.
Vi försöker samarbeta väldigt mycket sins emellan.
Ja, sen är det väl, det släpptes precis, jag var inne på Sweaty Business här två minuter innan vi satte igång podden och då var det en artikel om dig faktiskt, att ni säljer två anläggningar nu precis.
Det stämmer.
Första maj så kommer memb 24 att ta över gymmet Västerås och gymmet Örebro.
Det måste kännas lite konstigt.
Alltså, jag tänkte säga att det är blandade känslor.
Det här har ju varit något som har varit på tapeten ett tag.
Det är inte så att man fixar en försäljning över en natt.
Så jag känner väl att jag har hunnit bearbetare, men det är väl främst Västerås som jag känner är lite känsligare, för att det är ändå mitt gamla hemmagym.
Jag bodde i Västerås i två år när vi startade upp där.
Så det känns verkligen som att det är mitt gym som jag säljer.
Så det är lite mer känslor inblandade i just denna anläggningen.
Men samtidigt så försöker jag tänka att var sak har sin tid.
Så det är väl så där.
Ja.
Men är detta, jag gissar att detta är för att du ska få mer tid eller ni ska få mer tid och fokusera på mer ett visst område liksom.
Ja men precis, det blir ju väldigt mycket så att liksom kunna vara på så många orter samtidigt är omöjligt.
Och både jag och föräldran vill ju driva våra gym som vi vill.
På det sättet som vi tycker är bra och det blir jättesvårt om man inte kan vara på plats själv.
Och nu är det ju så att jag har inte varit varken i Västerås eller Örebro sedan i somras.
Vilket känns jättedåligt.
För det är inte så jag vill driva en gymanläggning.
Jag vill kunna vara på plats, jag vill kunna stötta personalen, jag vill kunna synas för medlemmar, jag vill kunna visa att jag liksom bryr mig om vad det är anläggning som vi har.
Och det är väl det jag känner att jag inte har kunnat med Västerås och Örebro på senaste.
Och ja, därav kom beslutet att det är nog bättre att låta någon annan som kan vara där, som har tiden för de anläggningarna, kan få ta över dem.
Ja, men ska jag då tolka det som att ni är ganska nöjda med den storleken som ni har nu, eller kommer det andra ställen fast mer?
Jag ska inte säga att vi kommer inte att starta något fler gym, för det kommer vi ju.
Det beror på vem vi frågar kanske.
Ja, men lite så.
Jag har ju sagt flera gånger att nu blir det inget mer gym och sen öppnar vi fler ändå.
Men vi har faktiskt signat, eller allting är inte helt färdigt, men vi har ett tillgym för det redan nu.
Så det kommer absolut fler anläggningar, men geografiskt bättre till för oss om man säger så.
Har du avslöjat vart det öppnas eller?
Nej men jag kan inte göra det för att allting inte är helt färdigt.
Vi väntar på godkännande hos kommunen och du vet lite sådana saker.
Men geografiskt bättre till för oss.
Kollar ni redan på nya sajter efter det eller är det, sen är det en liten paus.
Freddan är lite inne på en ny, som han och jag inte riktigt har lyckats övertala mig än.
Så vi får väl se.
Har ni alltid den processen?
För det låter lite grann på er som att, så som jag har förstått det så är Fredrik lite mer drivande i att öppna anläggningar och du är lite mer, varför är det ni själva som gör det?
Varför tar ni inte in ett team som öppnar anläggningar?
Alltså det får man ju säga att vi öppnar absolut inte själva.
Vi har ju ett helt team bakom oss.
Vi har ju en verksamhetschef uppe i Norrland och en verksamhetschef som utgår från Västerås nu, men det kommer ju bli väldigt mycket i Stockholm framöver då, för henne.
Så vi är absolut inte själva utan vi har ju ett jättebra team som hjälper till.
Men oavsett om man har det så är det extremt mycket mer jobb än vad man kan tänka sig och öppna en anläggning än liksom bara.
Det är ju många som skriver och önskar lite här och lite där och som får det att låta som att öppna här så kan jag hjälpa till, men det liksom det funkar inte så.
Jag kommer vara tvungen att göra mitt jobb på ett eller annat sätt och Fredan kommer vara tvungen att göra sitt jobb på ett eller annat sätt.
Om det ska starta på det sättet som vi vill.
Vi vill ju verkligen ha insyn i hur varje gym ser ut, hur det byggs upp, hur det möbleras, hur det liksom och det är verkligen så vi vill ha det.
Hade det varit så att vi hade gett det i någon annans händer och de hade fått möbleras om de vill, det hade tagits in vad som helst för maskiner, då hade det inte varit samma grej.
Vi vill ju liksom öppna det så som vi gillar att öppna gym.
Ni har inte funderat på att skapa någon sorts franchise-lösning där folk får skapa på.
Vi har fått frågan om det supermånga gånger och jättemånga som hade velat öppna gymmet, men det är samma där.
Då hade inte jag haft någon kontroll på att det är gymmets sköts precis som jag vill och även om man skriver avtal och sånt så blir det ju en svår sak om man själv inte är den som är ansvarig.
Så nej, det är nog inte aktuellt.
Du är ju lite avvaktande här till att öppna flera anläggningar.
Är du liksom nöjd där det är nu?
Är det det som är målet att, ja men det här är kul, jag får jobba med det jag vill, jag klarar av detta och det känns, nu stannar vi av här eller vad är det långsiktiga målet för dig?
Alltså ingen av oss jobbar ju speciellt långsiktigt kan jag ju säga.
Det låter kanske jättekonstigt och framförallt för de som är entreprenörer själva, då har man kanske en långsiktig plan att om fem år ska vi vara här eller om tio år ska vi ha gjort det här, men både jag och Fredan är ju väldigt impulsiva av oss, så det är liksom så här kommer man på en idé då vill man gärna göra det i morgon och lite så.
Så en långsiktig plan kan jag tyvärr inte säga att jag har, men jag tror vi kommer absolut öppna fler anläggningar, men jag tror att vi måste hitta någonting som funkar i längden, som gör att vi inte behöver flänga på samma sätt.
Så blir det fler anläggningar, ja men på de orterna vi redan finns, eller i nära anslutning till de orterna vi redan finns i.
Så det är väl det.
Vi tänker att vi får fokusera mycket på Norrland, och kanske Stockholmsområdet, Uppsala, vars vi redan har bra rullning och vars det är enkelt att ta sig.
Uppsala ligger nära Arlanda, Stockholm ligger nära Arlanda, där har vi liksom en timme flyg från Luleå.
Ska vi till andra orter som är längre bort, som typ Västerås eller Örebro är två timmar från Arlanda, då ska vi först till Arlanda och sen ska vi vidare två timmar och tillbaka.
Vad har ni gjort i den här högst märkliga geografiska öppnandet?
Alltså det är ju inte as smidigt.
Västerås var ju egentligen, Stockholm var ju från början verkligen, att vill man synas och höras så ska man finnas i Stockholm.
Så är det ju oavsett vilken bransch man är i.
Och efter Stockholm blev det Uppsala, för att Uppsala är väldigt nära Stockholm.
Och sen blev det Västerås.
Jo men ni bor väl i Luleå, gör ni inte det?
Nej vi bodde ju i Stockholm då.
Då bodde ni i Stockholm okej.
Ja vi bodde i Stockholm då.
Uppsala är ju väldigt smidigt även från Skulle, för att det är ju närmare Arlande än vad Stockholm till och med är.
Så så konstigt är det ju inte.
Och sen Västerås var ju också på grund av att det var nära Stockholm.
Vi bodde i Stockholm.
Sen flyttade vi till Västerås, och därav kom ju Örebro, för att det var nära Västerås.
Och sen fick vi barn och då valde vi att flytta hem till Luleå.
Och då var ju Örebro plötsligt inte alls så smidigt att ta sig till längre.
Så så kan man säga.
Men okej, skit i att det inte finns en långsiktig plan, men ni vill ändå vara inne i gymbranschen, eller har ni någon sorts tanke om att nu ska ni bygga upp ett litet, en kedja här och sen sälja av den och syssla med något annat, eller har ni någon sorts, vad är liksom förhoppningarna med hela insticket?
Alltså jag tror inte någon av oss har någon tanke på att vi liksom skulle ta oss ur gymbranschen helt.
Utan det är klart att det kan vara så att ja men, vi nu säljer Västerås och Örebro för att få det lättare geografiskt sätt, men det betyder inte att vi någonsin skulle kunna sälja till exempel Luleå som ändå är vår hemma stad och Kiruna som är liksom vår första, mamman till gymmen om man säger så.
Så nej jag tror absolut att vi kommer vara kvar i gymbranschen länge.
Ja, du har inte tröttnat på att prata träning och visa upp träning, ni lever ju ganska mycket träning.
Ja, men jag tänkte säga att det är ju mitt liv.
Jag hoppas ju att mina barn en dag vill ta över och göra samma sak som jag gör.
Sen vet man inte, de kanske kommer vara kräkless och bara usch mamma jag vill inte jobba med träning men jag hoppas ju att de kommer gilla det och kommer vilja vara med.
Jag har sagt det här i podden tidigare men för jag kan inte prata träning längre.
Alltså jag tycker det är det tråkigaste som finns.
Det finns så många människor som kommer fram och ska prata om vad de marklyfter eller vad de tränar och vad jag tycker är tråkigt att prata tränning.
Nej men alltså på ett slags sätt håller jag med dig.
Jag är väldigt ointresserad av vad någon annan har tagit i någon övning eller alltså ja nej det är så ointressant.
Jag kunde inte bry mig mindre men däremot så är jag väldigt intresserad av just det här och kunna hjälpa folk till en livsstil som är hälsosam som de trivs med.
Var i sig det handlar om att man tränar fem dagar i veckan eller en.
Liksom att man ändå har någonting som man känner att man trivs med sin vardag, där man trivs med att man har sin hälsa i behåll.
Så att just den biten är ju kanske mer intressant än själva lyft så tungt du bara kan eller, ja du fattar.
Ja, jag fattar, jag fattar.
Ni har ju en, om man vill gå in och kolla så kan man ju gå in och kolla på era bokföring och liknande.
Ni har ju en extremt linjär kurva.
Det är en väldigt väldigt stadig tillväxt och alla som har drivit gym eller känner någon som driver gym vet att det oftast är, antingen så lägger man ner det efter ett par år, man tjänar inga pengar alls eller så platoar man stenhårt.
Det är väldigt få gym som faktiskt växer och tjänar pengar.
Vad är det ni gör, alltså ni växte även under corona och gick plus under corona, vad är det som gör att ni faktiskt växer och går lönsamt hela tiden?
Vad är det ni gör bra?
Oj, bra fråga.
Inte så här att vi tar hand om kunderna, alla säger det.
Men jag tror faktiskt att mycket handlar om det.
Folk tar ju gymmet som sitt andra hem.
Det blir väldigt mycket så, men jag vet inte om du såg kommentarsfältet nu när vi gick ut med att vi säljer gymmet Västerås.
Det är så här, man kan tänka att det bara är ett gymm som får en ny ägare, men kommentarsfältet var ju verkligen att folk är superlässna.
De vill inte att vi ska sälja.
Och det handlar inte om att jag tror att de tycker illa om de som har köpt på något vis, utan det är snarare att de ser ju verkligen det som sitt andra hem och de ser mig och Freddan som de som äger deras andra hem.
Så jag tror faktiskt att mycket av varför det har gått så bra är på grund av det, att folk känner att det är sitt andra hem.
Men var ni lika aktiva, eller ni, det är väl mest du Fredrik, är väl inte lika aktiv utåt kanske, men har du varit lika aktiv?
Jag skulle nog säga att han är mer aktiv utepå gymmen, så jag skulle säga att våra medlemmar vet ju vem han är, även om han inte syns utåtsett på sociala medier.
Men har ni varit så hela tiden från start?
Nu är ni väldigt, eller du framförallt då kanske, stor i sociala medier och liknande.
Men var ni det när ni hade två gymm?
Alltså man kan ju säga att Instagram var ju inte alls stort när vi bodde i Luleå, när vi bara hade Kiruna och Luleå.
Det var ju när vi öppnade i Stockholm, det var ju typ då boomen med Instagram verkligen.
Och jag hade tur än att egentligen kunna haka på från början kan man säga.
Så...
Vad var det ni gjorde rätt under Luleå och Kiruna tiden då?
För det var inte riktigt samma, du vet, bubblor då på den tiden.
Nej, alltså...
Ja jag vet inte, man kan ju säga att Luleå från början när vi startade, det har ju absolut inte varit som...
Luleå fick ju också ett väldigt uppsving av att vi öppnade i Stockholm, och även att man syntes och hördes på ett annat sätt än vad man gjorde när vi bara var i Luleå och Kiruna.
Kiruna är ju så pass inarbetat att...
Ja, den skötte sig själv om man säger så.
Jag fattar.
Okej, men så det är hela den familjära grejen, är det det du skulle...
Så varumärket egentligen?
Ja, det tror jag, absolut.
Verkligen.
Jag tror också att vem som helst kan starta ett bra gym, med bra maskiner.
Alla har samma möjlighet att köpa exakt samma utrustning, ha samma möjlighet att göra exakt samma möblering som vi gör.
Så jag tror inte att...
Grunden i att gymmen går bra har att göra med vad det är för utrustning eller vad det är för.
Jag tror att mycket handlar om känslan som man får när man kommer in, och det är ju allting samlat.
Men framförallt personalen.
Får man ett hej, får man någon som ser en, får man någon som kan hjälpa en.
Och sen framförallt då...
Kanske det här med att det är undanplockat, det är städat, det är bra musik.
Så det är liksom en combo av allting, men det är själva känslan som gör att folk gillar att träna den.
Kan vi inte ta det lite grann?
Vem är det som anställer personalen?
Det är ju jag tillsammans med verksamhetscheferna i norr och söder.
Vad har ni för tankar när ni anställer folk då?
Vad är det ni tittar efter och vad är det som avgör om man ska få jobbet?
Alltså man kan ju säga att all vår personal är helt fantastiskt, har superhög arbetsmoral och det skulle jag säga är absolut viktigaste för att kunna få en tjänst hos oss och verkligen ha hög arbetsmoral, kunna vara spindeln i nätet om man säger så.
Och framförallt vara positiv, glad, liksom inte se några hinder när det kommer utan se möjligheter och kunna vara den som är lösningsorienterad, gillar att samtala med medlemmar, gillar att vara behjälplig.
Hur upptäcker ni det på intervjuer?
Alltså det är ganska svårt att hitta.
Alla kommer ju säga på en intervju att de är lösningsorienterade och, ja.
Jo men det är ju lite så.
Alltså vi går ju ändå ganska mycket också på, ja men att man kanske lite så här heddhantar att okej men den här tjejen som tränar på gym, att hon är alltid super social och super trevlig och super framåt, vi frågar henne.
Så det är ju inte heller alltid vi ens lägger ut en ansökan, utan då är det snarare att vi kan ha frågat någon, du är inte intresserad av att jobba här, och så blir det på den vägen.
Och annars kan det också vara att man har vi många ansökningar att man får försöka gå på magkänsla.
Fattar.
Skulle vi kunna få höra lite hur du är, när man tittar på dig utifrån och när man hör dig såhär, så är allting guld och gröna skogar och vackert.
Hur är du som chef eller ledare när personalen inte är så jävla trevlig, för det händer ju ibland.
Nu ska jag inte låta som att allting är guld och gröna skogar hela tiden.
Du menar att ni har inte haft en enda incident på ett enda djum under alla de här åren.
Jo det är klart att vi har haft någon incident.
Jag tror att jag har bett tre av mina kollegor hålla käften i dag.
Nej är det sant?
Nej, jag har nog faktiskt alldeles för bra personal.
Jag skulle nog säga att det är något till om jag kan inte ens komma ihåg när jag sist har haft en diskussion med den av vår personal.
Nu ser ju inte ni Anna, men jag ser hon såhär gör en sådan, nej nej, fan, prata inte om det här.
Nej, nej, jag fattar, det är bra personal helt enkelt.
Ni har en bra hemlamping att leda till.
Trots att allting är fantastiskt på gymmet när det gäller personal-
och ledarskapsfrågor, hur skulle du säga att du har utvecklats i chefskapet?
Vad är det, om du träffade dig själv för tio år sedan, kan du säga att du har blivit en mer vuxen människa och vad är du bättre på idag?
Vad är det man behöver göra för att driva tio gym istället för ett?
När det kommer till vilken personlighet man har eller hur man driver business.
Framförallt inse att man inte kan göra alla saker själv.
Jag har verkligen kontrollbehov, delux.
Jag vill gärna göra så mycket jag kan själv och det har jag fått inse med åren att det går ju inte.
Det spelar ingen roll om jag har tre gym eller tio, jag kan inte sitta och göra alla arbetsuppgifter själv.
Det har verkligen fått lära mig att jag måste vara bra på att dirigera vad andra ska göra och även lita på att de gör det bästa de kan.
Det har varit absolut bästa för mig också att inse, för idag har ju personal som är tusen gånger bättre än vad jag är på många arbetsuppgifter.
Så ensam är inte bäst, så är det.
Du nämnde att ni har verksamhetschefer, då är det två stycken som jag förstår rätt.
Hur har deras, hur har ni jobbat med dem för att de ska växa in i de rollerna?
Båda de har jobbat som anläggningsansvariga och klättrat uppåt kan man ju säga.
Så de båda vet ju exakt vad det innebär att vara anläggningsansvariga och vet hur det är att vara den personalen.
Så de har ju hand om personalen som sköter det de har gjort tidigare.
Jag tror ändå att det är ett bra sätt att gå, att man inte kommer in som en chef direkt, utan att man ändå vet hur det är att vara i situationen som personalen man har under sig är i.
Kan du se någon nackdel i att det är du och din kille som blir herre på täppan här.
Det kanske är svårt för folk att gå emot er och säga emot när det är ni som både äger och driver.
Oj vad svårt, den hade du nästan börjat fråga min personal.
Nej men jag tror ändå att vi har så pass bra dialog och kommunikation att personalen vågar säga om det är någonting som inte är bra.
Även komma med idéer och ha mycket egna synpunkter på att det här kanske inte är så bra, vi borde göra så här istället.
Så jag tror inte att de ser det som någonting negativt.
Att jag och Freddan är ett podd.
Då är det nog snarare tvärtom.
Att det är jag och någon personal som blir emot Freddan eller Freddan och någon personal som blir emot mig.
För jag och Freddan tycker väldigt mycket olika.
Men det är ganska bra, vad är det ni brukar tycka är olika om?
Förutom att öppna gym?
Allt.
Nej men det är så här, ska vi meblera?
Då brukar han säga till mig att det är inte konstigt att vi tycker olika om du vill sätta badpressen på toaletten.
Man bara ja nej, det går inte ens att diskutera för vi tycker så olika.
Men det är lite så här, vi får slåss med nebbor och klor för det vi vill få igenom och mötas någonstans.
Och det är oftast år att bygga och bli som bäst.
Jag är lite fascinerad över det.
Jag och min flickvän är, vi har sagt att vi kan aldrig någonsin jobba ihop.
Vi har helt olika sätt att fungera.
Ni jobbar ihop, ni driver gym ihop, ni har två barn, är det väl?
Och ni reser runt ganska mycket.
Det är ett jävla livspussel att få ihop.
Och det blir lite skumt.
Ofta när man är entreprenör så är en av partierna entreprenör och den andra har ett lite mer vanligt jobb.
Det brukar vara enklare så.
Hur löser ni allt detta?
Jag tror att det hade varit bättre.
Alltså jag tror att om någon av oss hade haft ett vanligt jobb då tror jag det hade varit svårt att förstå den andra.
Nu är det ju väldigt här, vi båda jobbar lika mycket, vi jobbar för samma sak.
Vi förstår ju varför den andra jobbar mycket och vi försöker verkligen underlätta livspusslet privat för varandra.
Det tror jag hade varit svårt om man inte hade förstått.
Om man själv hade haft ett sju fyra jobb och när man kommer hem så gör man inte längre.
Då tror jag att det hade varit svårt att förstå den andra situationen.
Vi är ju ändå väldigt så här, vi förstår varandras situation och vi försöker hjälpa så mycket som möjligt.
Så man kan ju säga att det enda vi är oense om det är när vi ska bygga gym.
Eller när vi ska bli...
Annars är vi liksom ett team och försöker på allting att funka.
Så om det någon gång blir en skilsmässa då vet ni att det är för att vi har försökt öppna ett gym och vi har inte kommit över ens.
Men kan ni ta med er det?
Kan ni stänga av det?
Om du har sett How I Met Your Mother, de har ju en sån switch du vet.
Man tar en paus när man bråkar.
Och när man har småbarn så tjafsar man julland.
Och kan ni gå in på jobbet och bara, ja fan vi har haft världens bråk hemma men nu ska vi diskutera medlemskapskostnader.
Alltså vi har typ aldrig bråk hemma faktiskt.
Det enda vi har bråk är ju på jobbet.
Fan det är någonting med Luleå, det finns inga bråk, det finns ingen personal som tjafsar, det finns ingen som...
Nej men jag tror att det blir såhär...
Om någon lyssnar på detta och ser hur någon personal på gymmet beter sig lite dåligt mot andra, kan ni väl filma det och skicka hit?
Vi ska väl lägga upp det någonstans.
Jävla trevlig arbetsplats detta.
Inga bråk med två...
Hur gammal är den yngsta?
Han är tio månader.
Så han ska snart börja gå här nu då.
Ja han är överallt.
Någon gång ska ni bråka i alla fall, det blir väl då.
Nej men jag tror att då är det snarare att man själv känner att man blir...
Det är tiden som man inte hinner med.
Jag ska kunna jobba, jag är inte mamaledig, samtidigt som Max härjar runt.
Då är det ännu viktigare för mig och Fredan att ha en bra kommunikation.
Okej, du måste ta Max nu för att jag ska ha det här mötet, eller kan du ta honom här för att jag ska hinna träna.
Och vice versa liksom.
Så jag tror inte att, vi kommer nog inte bråka på grund av att han flänger överallt, men man lär ju garanterat känna av att man har mindre tid.
Jag är väldigt fascinerad över par som kan jobba ihop.
Jag hade intervju här med Andreas på Tyngre för ett par månader sedan och han jobbar ihop med sin fru.
De sitter dessutom hemma och jobbar med, jag kommer inte ihåg hur många unga det var, men det är ju ett gäng liksom.
De har ynglat av sig ordentligt.
Det är ju imponerande.
Har ni haft investerare efter er under den här perioden?
Det har ju varit någon som kanske har slängt ut sig i farten, men absolut ingenting seriöst, nej.
Det är ändå lite förvånande, det finns ju inte så många fristående kedjer.
Nej, så kan det väl vara.
Det var lite intressant, hade ni varit intresserade?
Nej, alltså det tror jag faktiskt inte.
Då tror jag att för oss är det ju bättre att som idag sälja av två gym än att ta in en investerare.
Jag tror inte att varken jag eller Fredan hade velat att någon annan skulle ha att säga till om, om man säger så.
Vi tycker att det är nog att diskutera oss emellan när vi inte kommer överens eller tycker likadant.
Skulle vi haft en tredje som har sina åsikter så känns det som att det hade blivit ännu svårare.
Ja.
Jag är lite fascinerad av er drivkraft här.
För att du nämnde ju till exempel i andra intervjuer att ni startade gym och du tröttnade lite på att starta gym eller du ville ta det lugnt och sen började ni starta gym igen.
Och nu så sålde ni två gym för att få lite bättre geografisk spridning.
Men sen väljer ni att öppna gym igen.
Och du sa att ni funkar rätt luststyrt så ni går på det som funkar.
Alltså, någonstans måste ni ändå tänka på vad ni gör.
Jo men det är klart man gör det.
Ja men som jag sa, nu när vi säljer Västerås och Örebro, det beror ju på att vi känner att vi inte har tiden att vara på de anläggningarna.
Och ska vi starta nya gyms så vill vi att det ska vara, vi vill ju jobba med gymmen, men vi vill kunna göra det på ett sätt som är möjligt i våra privata.
Vad är det som gör att ni väljer att starta gymmen?
Är det för att det är bara jävligt kul att ha fler gymm?
Alltså det är ju kul att starta gymm, det är det absolut.
Bara den här känslan av, som nu när vi startar Gustavsberg, det är ju en speciell känsla att få öppna en anläggning som man bara wow, alltså det här blev bra.
Det är kul också att öppna någonting som man ser, att när folk kommer så är de så himla positiva och glada.
Man ser bara träningsklädje och man bara får den här positiviteten när man kommer på plats.
Det är något speciellt med det.
Det är väl det som gör att man ändå har velat starta fler än att stanna vid Stockholm.
Sen är det ju klart att det finns för-
och nackdelar.
Nackdelarna är ju hur extremt mycket jobb det är med att starta var det är anläggning.
Så det är ju därför att jag gick verkligen att jag kommer inte att öppna fler gym efter Västerås-anläggningen.
Det var för att vi öppnade Uppsala i oktober tror jag.
Sen flyttade vi hela gymmet Kiruna till större lokaler och öppnade det i början på mars.
Nej, i början på maj.
Sen åkte jag snabbt ner till Tyskland och opererade Kerstin, vår hund, kom tillbaka och öppnade gymmet Västerås.
Jag kan säga att den öppningen, mina ögon var så räddsprängda så jag vet inte ens om jag såg någonting.
Jag hade inte sovit ordentligt på garanterat för flera månader och den sista veckan knappt någonting.
Det var några enstaka timmar per natt.
Det var efter den som jag kände att det var droppen, det blir inget fler gymm.
Det hann ju gå ett tag innan vi öppnade i sumpan sen.
Jag var verkligen såhär, nej det här kommer jag inte att göra igen.
Det finns inte en chans i världen.
Men sen är det klart man hinner smälta det och man hinner bara såhär, okej, fast det kommer inte bli lika hemskt igen, för det kommer inte vara så många gymm samtidigt.
Så då hinner man glömma bort hur jobbigt det var och så kör man ändå.
Ja, du har ju sagt lite att det är han Fredrik som pushar lite för detta.
Vad är hans dröm med detta?
Kan du se att han har någon längre plan eller förhoppning?
Han är ju väldigt likt mig också när det kommer till det att vi gör saker här och nu.
Så jag tror han har inte heller någon lång plan utan nu är han inne på det djumet som vi förhoppningsvis ska kunna starta och sen har han ett till som han hade velat som han inte riktigt har fått med mig på ännu men vi får väl se.
Så han jobbar väl också för det just nu men inte för någon längre framtidsplan eller så.
Vad är det för argument som brukar vinna över dig till slut?
Ja, det låter liksom som att han pitchar två argument per dag ungefär.
Lite så, han skojar vi har ju, men hon som är verksamhetschef här uppe i norr, hon är ju väldigt med på att klart vi ska öppna flera anläggningar här i Krokena.
Så hon är ju alltid på hans sida.
Så då blir det verkligen så här, ja vi måste bara övertala Annis så löser det sig.
Så ja, det är två mot en.
Ja, jag förstår.
Det är fint, kul att vara bromsklossen i gänget.
Exakt.
Kan du inte berätta lite mer om appen här, eftersom du lägger så pass mycket tid på den, trots att den ändå är omsättningsmässigt kanske som ett gym.
Så giss jag att antingen tycker du är väldigt, väldigt kul eller så tror du att det kan bli väldigt, väldigt bra.
Alltså man kan ju säga så här, appen omsätter ju mer än vad ett gym gör.
Och appen har inte samma omkostnader som ett gym har.
Så det är ett lättare produkt att jobba med.
Absolut.
Sen älskar jag sättet som vi jobbar med appen.
Kan du inte beskriva appen lite för det är säkert många.
Gymet känner ju de flesta till.
Gymet är som det heter gymet men appen känner nog inte alla till.
Appen det är ju en produkt som vi har både kost och träning i.
Så man kan följa mina träningsprogram eller mina kollegors träningsprogram.
Man kan följa massa olika pass.
Vi har follow along pass om man vill starta på TVn och köra som vi kör.
Man kan träna hemma, man kan träna på gymmet.
Vi har ju en kostdel med både kostplaner man kan följa, recept, massvis med recept, bara hälsosamma recept som är enkla och verkligen som folk uppskattar.
Som vi uppdaterar varje vecka.
Så det kommer alltid nyheter och det kommer alltid att finnas någonting som passar för alla om man säger så.
Vi är ju ett helt gäng som jobbar med att hela tiden uppdatera appen, se till att den uppdateras med träningsprogram, med recept, med funktionerna som finns där om man säger så.
Är tanken att det ska bli någon sorts livsstilsapp, liksom man ska även väga in sömn och stress och jag vet inte, allt sånt här.
Ja men det, vi utvecklar ju den hela tiden, så planen är ju absolut att hela tiden få mer funktioner och få mer sådant som är användarvänligt och uppskattat.
Och jag älskar ju jobba med den just där, den anledningen att jag når ut till så många fler än vad jag gör på gymmen.
För sig då att vi kanske har några tusen medlemmar på vardera gymm, men appen kan ju verkligen nå ut till hela Sverige.
Du behöver inte finnas liksom i Luleå eller i Stockholm för att använda den, utan är du nere i Skåne?
Ja men absolut.
Så ja, den är rolig att jobba med och det är en så tacksam produkt för att de flesta som har den är ju ändå sådana som, hurra av sig för att de tycker att det är så himla roligt, de har fått resultat, de är nöjda över det de har åstadkommit, de är nöjda med tjänsten och produkten.
Nej men det är helt fantastiskt att jobba med den.
Tänk rent privatmässigt, kan du tycka att det är jobbigt att vara offentlig eller att bli igenkänd och liknande?
Nej, jag kanske blir igenkänd men det är inte så många som kommer fram eller skulle säga nånting så, så jag har aldrig upplevt det som ett problem.
Det är inte så att du går och skäms när du tränar för att du måste tänka att idag måste jag köra hårt för alla förväntar sig att jag ska köra hårt.
Nej verkligen inte.
Jag frågade Daniel på Styrke labbet samma grej, men han har ju ett hemmagym så han kan köra där.
Nej.
Nej okej, det är inte så att du upplever att folk springer efter dig på stan och ska fråga hur man äter ett protein.
Nej, nej.
Vad är de olika, jag hoppar lite här så du märker det för att jag vill få med alla områden.
Vad är de svåraste perioderna förutom att öppningarna verkar vara ett slitsamma så har det funnits några ögonblick när ni är liksom, nej, fan vi skiter i detta, eller det här var tufft.
Finns det några tunga ögonblick?
Oj, nu tänker jag här, men...
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Helvete vad Norrland levererar.
Vi har absolut haft några kolleger som kanske inte har varit de bästa för vårt företag.
Men de är ju så pass få att i det stora hela så är de inte någonting som man liksom lägger på minnet eller tänker att de ska kunna ta ens energi om man säger så.
Ni har inte haft någon likviditetskris, ni har inte haft någon öppning när det blev vattneträkvår, ni har inte haft inget sånt.
Nej, som tur är så har vi ändå varit ganska stabila.
Klart att vi haft öppningar som man bara okej, i det här gymmet trodde vi skulle gå bättre än vad det kanske har gjort.
Men då har ju vi ändå ett så pass starkt bolag att det har funnits andra som har kunnat lyfta upp det.
Så det är aldrig så att man har känt att okej nu sitter vi i skiten för att vi har öppnat ett gym som inte har gick som vi tänkte, utan då har ju ändå, klart att det är surt om vi har ett gym som inte går som vi har tänkt, men det är inte så att vi, man hakar upp sig på det.
Skulle det kunna vara så att du helt enkelt är maniskt optimistisk för att det låter inte så jävla verkligt detta.
Men jag är nu absolut en optimist, men jag tror att saker och ting blir lättare om jag tänker positivt.
Skulle jag fokusera på det negativa och alltså saker som drar ner mig, ja men då är ju det min verklighet också.
Om jag fokuserar på det som är positivt och hela tiden väljer att lyfta det, ja men då är det det som är min verklighet.
Och jag gillar ju hellre att vara positiv och fokusera på de positiva sakerna än att haka upp mig på det som är dåligt.
Ja, jag skulle säga att det faktiskt låter så.
Nu kan inte folk se dig men du tänker faktiskt efter.
Det är inte så att du bara sitter och bullshittar att allting är bra utan du verkar faktiskt ha lite svårt att hitta saker som är tunga men det är klart som fan att tio gym har en del utmaningar.
Jag skulle nog säga att det tuffaste i min gymkarriär det var ju nu att ta beslutet att sälja Västerås.
Framförallt prata med personalen som har jobbat med oss jättelänge.
Den var inte rolig.
Jag valde åka ner till Västerås för att prata med de som har jobbat längst.
Hon som har jobbat längst har varit med sen start, sen vi öppnade gymet Västerås.
Det var jättetufft för det känns verkligen som att det är inte bara en av våra kollegor eller våra anställda, utan man kommer ju varandra så nära när man har jobbat med varandra så länge.
Vi är som ett familjeföretag fast vi jobbar nära våra anställda.
Jag tror att det mycket är positivt med det, men när det blir en sån här grej så är det kanske inte så positivt.
Det blir ett mycket jobbigare beslut att ta än vad det kanske hade behövt vara annars, om det bara hade varit business.
Jag fattar precis.
Jag tänker att det är rätt många människor som vill driva gym eller som vill starta gym, men som inte får till det.
Vad gör de för fel?
Jag tror absolut att det är många som tror att de kan starta gym och liksom bli stenrika direkt och tänker att det här är världens bästa affärsidé och starta ett gym och tjäna jättemycket pengar.
Det kommer inte hända.
Alltså du kommer vara tvungen att jobba skitmycket innan du kommer kunna tjäna pengar, oavsett liksom.
För det kostar jättemycket pengar att starta gym.
Så där tror jag att många gör fel.
Man kollar på gymskedjorna och tänker att det är superenkelt och tänker att man ska göra samma sak och tjäna jättemycket pengar, men man lägger inte ner sin hjärta och själv.
Man fattar inte hur mycket jobb det faktiskt är innan det börjar gå plus och visa bra siffror.
Det är liksom en inställningsfråga från start nästan.
Jag tror mycket det.
Folk tänker att det ska vara jättelätt och att det kommer gå jättebra direkt, men du kommer ju vara tvungen att jobba för att det ska gå bra.
Att man vill in i tränningsbranschen som ändå är rätt, full av människor som är okej med att jobba gratis.
Det finns ganska många som jobbar som PT, som inte tar ut en riktig lön eller som driver ett gym och inte tar ut en riktig lön.
Eftersom du ändå har startat både gym och app och klädmärke och även driver en...
Du hade ju kunnat tjäna pengar på din sociala presence också om du hade velat.
Om man vill in i någon av de där områdena och faktiskt lyckas där, har du något tips för hur man ska...
Inte bara att man ska jobba hårt utan finns det liksom...
Fan, det här borde du tänka på.
Jag tror ju mycket på att inte fokusera så mycket på vad alla andra gör och tänka att den här människan gjorde det här och det går svinbra, jag gör samma sak.
För då kommer du alltid bara vara en copy-paste.
Gör liksom det som du själv tror på och fokusera verkligen på det du själv kan stå bakom.
För det tror jag kommer just igenom.
Kan du komma med någonting som inte alla andra gör?
Ja men då har du ju absolut en möjlighet att växa.
Kommer du och ska göra samma sak som flera andra personer redan gör?
Vad är det som säger att det kommer gå bra för dig då?
Jag gillar det tipset för det känns faktiskt som att ni lever det också.
Det känns ju som att gymmen till exempel har lite egen utformning eller ni har gjort lite er egna grej på vissa ställen.
Det tycker jag folk ska ta till sig av.
Ni är ju också ganska halvnördiga ibland med att testa maskiner och liknande och kika runt och sånt där.
Har du någon spaning på vad du tror kommer komma här framöver?
Finns det några trender som är intressanta?
Är det någonting?
Det här kikar vi på.
Alltså inte något sådär som jag tänker är spontant, men jag tror ju mycket av det som kommer framöver kommer att handla om att hitta en livsstil som man mår bra av, som man trivs av alltid.
Och då tror jag att mycket handlar om att träningsformerna inte alltid bara behöver vara gym och styrketräning, utan det kan lika väl vara att man vill kombinera sin styrketräning med löpning eller man vill kombinera sin styrketräning med någon annan typ av kondition eller hemma träning kanske till och med.
Jag tror att vi kommer att komma mer och mer in i att det viktigaste är att få träningen gjord.
Sen behöver inte alla pass vara stenhårda pass på gymmet och i just styrketräningsdelen, utan det kan lika väl vara att jag körde ett Pilatespass hemma och det var svinbra och jag mådde jättebra efteråt.
Det känns ganska rimligt.
Folk behöver steppa upp sin livsstil lite och slappna av samtidigt.
Ja men jag tror det, absolut.
Och jag tror också att det har att göra med det att tidigare kanske var såhär okej men du tränar på gym och du är jättefokuserad på din gymtränning medans nu blir ju hälsa mer och mer att gemene man förstår att man behöver ta hand om sig.
Det blir ju också att målgruppen för hälsa har blivit så pass mycket större idag än vad den var förut.
Är det någonting som ni aktivt jobbar med för att fånga upp dem?
Eller är det ni jobbar med appen här till exempel men själva gymmen känns ju ändå rätt hardcore för många?
Alltså vi försöker ju verkligen jobba mot att gymmet ska vara för alla och inte bara för de som är supernördiga.
Så vi har ju mycket såhär, samarbeta med i livet i att man får en månad gratis om man signar upp sig med gymkort på gymmet, att då får man hjälp med kost och träning en månad.
Vi har ju gratis instruktion på gymmaskinerna så att man verkligen får en bra start och får se hur allting funkar.
Vi har ju väldigt bra bemannade appetiter på alla gymm för att det ska kunna finnas personal som finns till hands för de som känner att de behöver eller vill ha hjälp, inte bara komma och köra sitt eget.
Jättejättebra!
Anna, jag ska inte ta mer av din tid.
Jag vet att du lever ett aktivt liv.
Du verkar flyga runt en del och jobba lite grann även med två gym nedlagda.
Så att jag får säga ett stort enormt tack för att du tog din tid och var med i podden.
Ja men tack för att jag fick vara med.
Ni har inte haft någon likviditetskris, ni har inte haft någon öppning när det blev vattenläckor, ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Helvete vad Norrland levererar!
Jag tror jag har bett tre av mina kolleger hålla käften idag.